marvel fans i am here with marissa tonay
how's it going i'm going good getting
very excited for everyone to see this
movie it's the big the big opening the
energy is amazing i'm so excited yeah
it's very it's really thrilling so what
has may been up to since we last left
off
uh
well her and peter parker have gone
through a lot together they're growing
up they've been through several cycles
of on and off relationships with other
people
i don't know they're hanging out
i mean that's a lot
uh so everyone knows that peter parker
is spider-man how is may handling that
i think that well well may was shocked
at first
and then
you know then she found out and
they became a team they just really work
together
and
um
she's in on it with him and she also
tries to protect the part of him that's
still a boy and lets him do his thing i
love that so i need you to spill the tea
all right
may has kind of a different
understanding when it comes to her
relationship with happy
uh
what is their relationship there what's
going on i don't i don't think i mean
there's a relationship there's a
friendship and they've also they're like
compadres they've been through so much
together they've been lovers they've
been friends they've been on they've
been off i don't know why you think i
have a different why do you have a
different understanding i mean the last
movie it was kind of like a little back
and forth oh yeah yes yes yes true
uh what was it like to work with this
incredible cast again oh it's just so
great to see uh to see them they're
always doing something new and different
and they they just they're so beautiful
they're beautiful to look at they're
beautiful inside and uh it's always fun
to come back and be with them again well
i'm excited to see you on the big screen
tonight i won't keep you from the red
carpet thank you for spending time with
us thanks thanks to you
[Music]
you